okay let's talk about the live shows
baby that middle class famous tour
that's a good good time that
middle-class famous tour we're coming to
a city near you it's a stand-up comedy
show then we play a little ayg with the
crowd fantastic way to introduce new
people to the show grab your best guy
grab your best gal grab your girlfriends
grab your guy friends bring the whole
squad and come see us yeah gang next
week uh september 13th we're going to be
in kansas city then september 14th we're
going to be in springfield all right
then in september 15th we're going to be
in st louis then in october coming to
nashville we're going to indy november
we're going to philly's second show out
of there that's almost sold out get
those tickets don't sleep on that then
we're coming to providence rhode island
and boston in december those shows are
sold out at the moment but we're adding
tickets be on the lookout yeah
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage oh yeah little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find that they're good to be classy or
they're just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here in
auntie's basement she just got a brand
new ankle bracelet okay good for her i
ain't talking about kay jewelers either
pity's going to be home for a little
while
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the ceo of ru garbage
he is an international businessman he's
the prince of park avenue but always the
king of the boardwalk baby give it up
for kj kevin james ryan hey gang thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube as you know
those numbers are true
almost at a hundred thousand let's go
let's go and then obviously the greatest
website of all time
are you www.patreon.com a lot of that
money baby check it the [ __ ] out yes
siren having a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good he works the
ones and twos crosses the t's and dots
the eyes and he's no stranger to a kick
flip i can tell you that right now give
it up for t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen
everybody what up dudes t-bone i'm so
hyped um i've never wanted to guess i
think i'm cool more in my entire life
he's been doing heel flips all morning
dude he's [ __ ] stoked right now
dude's a poser man
oh my god oh man t-bone is all excited
we are all excited we couldn't be more
excited to have our incredibly special
guest here with us today for the fourth
time he's a professional skateboarder
and podcaster he is team manager at s
shoes mob grip and richter wheels he is
also a team writer at lrg he is
sponsored by visit skateboards and you
can hear him every week on the amazing
podcast the nine club but the big
question about his mind today is he
garbage i don't know about all that but
he's a cool dude he's got a sweet name
and the kids [ __ ] smooth his ice on
the skateboard
give it up for kelly hart everybody
let's go
yo thank you bro that was incredible
that was first take that was first tank
that was insane you guys are amazing
[Laughter]
oh man i love this guy
he came in laughing i'm like this is my
kind of [ __ ] guy yo thanks for having
me thanks for coming buddy thank you for
coming give us give us the back story
l.a kid los angeles well tech laguna
hills from orange county uh grew up
skateboarding playing baseball
basketball football really yeah i was a
full-on jock for days nice
uh i two sisters uh
i got her dad i got a mom
this guy's got a mom
kid's doing all right yeah
where'd you meet that
i have an older dad i was like okay
i got an older dad
what is laguna hills it's right next to
laguna beach um it's a cool neighborhood
it's it's you know it's super it's
pretty nice a little bit of cash a bit
of what a little bit of cash yeah yeah
laguna beach would be
i mean it's like middle class nice you
know what i mean uh parents have
families my dad's at er doctor mom's a
nice nurse okay my sister's a lawyer her
husband's a plastic no uh orthopedic
surgeon
a dentist her husband's a oral surgeon
and i'm just a skateboarder
yeah kind of got in front of the
7-eleven
but yeah no it's super cool i think i
was the the baby boy so they kind of
like let me do whatever like you know i
think when parents i don't know i don't
have kids but when they had their my
first sister they were real strict
and then they had another one they were
all strict on her and then i'm the baby
boy and they're like oh he's cool let
him go yeah i never got detention in
high school i was like super nice little
kid i just paid attention to what i
wanted to do
i got into skateboarding and it just
took over my life what age yeah i
started skating i think 11 years old
okay and um
it like i played sports and everything
like that but i in high school i figured
like
i don't like having like a schedule like
hey you have to go to practice after
school and practice for two hours and do
all that stuff and that was all year
because i played every sport damn and so
then i was and i was skating on the side
and then i kind of just hey mom i'm i'm
done how did you see where what was the
first skateboard that you were like
exposed to because it's always like an
older kid in the neighborhood or there's
always like some sort of romance where
you're like oh i want to do what that
kid's [ __ ] doing for sure
my so my parents had a beach house in
san clemente i grew up surfing okay and
then my my neighbor he came skating down
the street one day and he just had a
skateboard i saw him and his little
brother and my friend i was like whoa
what and then i kind of had one before
but it was like i'd ride down the
driveway in my ass like you know you're
just a little kid you know i did the
same thing you're speaking my language
that's as far as i got yeah i skid my
knee and i was like i'm going back to
football well dude like when i was a kid
too is like you would go i had lived in
this hill so i would my mom would buy me
a brand new pair of shoes and i'd get on
the board and just fire down the hill
putting my feet on my ass on the ground
destroy a pair of shoes in literally an
hour and she would just get super pissed
but
anyway my friends skated down they
showed me you could do this thing called
ollie and i kind of just was like well
that's kind of cool and then i started
to learn it it took a long time to learn
like that first stuff but then you
realize there was this open like huge
vast
world you could live like just
all the spots that are out there all the
tricks you could do and it was just kind
of eye-opening and i kind of just went
down the rabbit hole you got into like
the scene and all that stuff yeah it
took a while to get in there because i
there wasn't really a big skate scene i
mean there was but it was like i don't
know there wouldn't skaters at my school
okay um how old do you feel mommy asking
i'm 37. so when you were because when i
was a kid there was no skate parks there
was none of that stuff it was all like
104 years ago
back in my day
you whip the snappers on your skateboard
you're going to scare my horse what are
you doing young man
but no it was all like uh you know it
was like parking lots and stuff like
that kids getting chased out and stuff
like that and i feel like it wasn't
until you guys generation where people
started you know like where it started
to become a little more amazing a little
more mainstream at that time once we're
the same and i skated too i was horrible
i never really got past the ollie i was
good at cruising
um but no like that's it was there was
like a bit of a boom i feel like that
for for kids that age at that time like
the early 2000s or whatever yeah i think
you know my friends started doing it and
then i saw skate videos and that's what
really opened my eye because you're like
well i didn't
there was a video called uh toby knows
four and one yeah and uh
it was just like this
these
like monthly bi-monthly videos that came
out that just showed you skateboarding
and you got to like hear the music to
see the way they dressed and i was
introduced to like you know southern
california skateboarding and then east
coast skateboarding and seeing like
philadelphia new york but i'm like this
little white kid in like you know orange
county and i'm like this is so [ __ ]
cool i didn't know that there was like
this big world of like
just
there's no organized like there's no
organization up here sure just go out
and do what you want to do you know what
i mean and so that's what kind of like
led me to it and
literally just took over we talk about
this all the time seinfeld jerry
seinfeld said this in uh either
comedians and cars or something like
that he said you know who's going to be
all right is the skateboard guys because
you see them and you know that it they
had to fall so many times to be able to
perfect something yeah like just getting
back up and doing it again i think that
is the big parallel with stand up too
and i started watching uh all those
epically later oh yeah from way back and
uh just like
this was like a few years ago and it's
like
with stand up or you know with stand up
and skateboard it's it's success through
constant failure yeah it's like you only
succeed one out of a hundred times yeah
whether it's a joke whether it's landon
trigger or whatever so it's like it's
that constant failure that i was like oh
it's so similar mentality-wise yeah i
trip out because you i feel like comedy
like when you guys sell a joke and it
bombs or something like you're just
taking that emotional yeah
that emotional beating right there and
then skateboarding is like more more
physical sure yeah like your horse
you're just like falling falling forward
that's the thing it's it's it's wild uh
i always just tripped on that i trip out
on you guys doing stand-up and you guys
are hilarious but like it's like wild
for me to like get up in front of people
and just be like this you got i watched
something you guys just like you know
what else is while jumping down 10
stairs yeah all right
yeah i'd rather bomb and fall off a
loading dock i'm not going to lie to you
you guys are crazy telling jokes for 12
people
you're olly enough to [ __ ] release
the house i totally would rather get
like bomb instead of jumping off a
little bit
what is the broken bone situation today
uh
dislocated my ankle
once or i broke ankle
oh my gosh foot once
ankle dislocation once uh broke my ankle
another time and then
i had a hip surgery like out of nowhere
like i had this thing called hip
impingement that kind of would like
slowed me down
wait was it because of skating just
repetitive skateboarding for 20 years
it was this one day i was like oh my god
what is that i didn't know what it was i
had to go
look into it and uh like luckily one guy
came on our show and kind of had the
same problem and then i was like i need
to look into that and then i saw his
doctor he's like oh yours is way worse
than his you're like you're [ __ ] dude
i was like goddamn you could have asked
your dad
anybody in your family could have taken
care of that there might be a concussion
thrown in there i'm not gonna lie to be
honest that was the cool thing is that i
remember when i broke my foot the first
time i had called my brother-in-law and
he was like oh yeah you have this this
one injury ball either by telling him
what he means
you need to get surgery now that's what
he told me about my hip he did say that
right he did the x-ray you scared the
[ __ ] out of me dude
this guy's awesome
first off i'm waiting in like the
waiting room for him and he's like he
opened the door and three dudes walk in
and they're holding this huge syringe
full of like brown [ __ ]
like so we're gonna need you to calm
down and i was like what the [ __ ] i'm
here for an x-ray dude
hey put the junk away yeah all right you
need to get down he starts putting like
we heard stop stop and then my brother
walks in and he's like got you [ __ ] oh
i was like dude
you can't do that the medical field
that's [ __ ] up these guys are janitors
it's not a frat house
but yeah no it's a lot of injuries and
like whatever but you just it's the
funny thing about skateboarding man you
eat [ __ ] and you destroy yourself and
that whole one year that you're out
you're like i just want to skate i just
want to skate and then you somehow
you get back into it that's how long it
is sometimes it'll be like a year yeah
it could be depending on what it is yeah
it's super nuts now still going hang out
when the other guys are skating and
stuff like that with the cast on and
[ __ ] yeah but dude didn't you gotta
crutch around that's the way hey wait up
guys yeah
and like that's the worst part like i i
hope don't break that would have been my
move i would have put a fake cast on
yeah i'm sorry i can't
all tricked out in van's gear
you've been injured for 14 years yeah
you know i don't know county man back
home i really tore it up
yeah that's like my girlfriend went to
another school
she's really hot you don't know her
that's awesome yeah that that's the
whole side of skateboarding sucks but
this is what you go through you know
what i mean has anyone gotten injured
doing stand-up
uh maybe somebody attack him on stage or
something yeah but nothing uh doesn't
yanis used to giannis is falling off how
people have fallen off stage yeah but
nothing like skateboarding
that shit's [ __ ] wild yeah i i trip
out because like there's segments and
videos like the slam section you're like
dude i can't i can't watch that oh yeah
when they're like jumping over the
stairs and [ __ ] just catch it wrong
like when that's what's crazy people
people when you watch skate videos they
land in the videos they're usually
landing every trick right they put the
music to it you land all the tricks
people don't know how many times people
destroyed themselves
like i
would have the gnarliest swell bows
growing up like like a couple curser
sacks like there's
my hips were just like swollen as [ __ ]
because you're just like constantly
falling
but like the funny there's a couple of
people like knock hell smith the
professional skateboarder awesome he
like you just learned how to fall yeah
and so he'd fall into spring off the
ground yeah it looked like it didn't
even hurt like a stunt man yeah let's
figure out how to do it yeah and that's
i think with skateboarding you have to
learn how to fall which is weird that's
[ __ ] sweet man did you go to school
did you go to college went to high
school didn't even do the sats
i went to community college for like a
year and then my mom was like uh i got
swan i didn't tell her that i was like
going out skating
uh and i one day like she uh check came
to the house and she's like what what is
this and i was like oh i got sponsored
and they're like
what are you doing i'm like i don't know
you want me to go to college or just or
community college i just went yeah
there's like yeah they asked me to go to
barcelona uh next month
new video she's like
just get stopped going to school and
just go do what you want i got on board
real quick yeah [ __ ] cash showed up
it was like it was
i'm out of here dad
i just need a first-class ticket to
barcelona and i'm going
it was but it was cool like that they
let me just they always supported me but
it's awesome that is awesome it was a
cool thing that like they didn't push me
down this like crazy medical like road
or college road or anything so that's
kind of cool
you got leukemia dude
you're not gonna make it man
i just ate [ __ ] lunch dude what are
you doing
[Laughter]
that was a good one
ah that's funny man i love this episode
this is all right
do your parents still live in the uh in
the same house that you grew up in my
mom is in the same house my dad lives
somewhere else now but uh so in laguna
hills but it's cool to like go home and
like my house is better
i grew up skating in my driveway and
that's like
i cherish that place oh that's awesome i
live in venice beach now nice yeah so
not to give the address away of your of
your mom's house but was it a boulevard
was it an avenue
cul-de-sac
so it was perfect it was like i had my
driveway i had this it was like i had
this driveway and then my neighbor's
driveway was like there was like a grass
gap in the middle so i could skate those
are great perfect little flat gap and
then i had a box and a flat bar grid
flat ground and my whole street was just
like perfectly paved and it was like
yeah so they would constantly see you
out there so they knew you were that you
were very serious oh i was insane i must
have pissed off my neighbors so much
just like hearing the skateboarding
no nonstop i'd be out there till
midnight just trying to like learn [ __ ]
you know what i mean but it's
thank you to my neighbors and my mom
yeah for letting me be a maniac
jeez there's a couple of trucks
here's a set of bearings get out of here
uh what was uh the high school mascot
the hawks nice that's good yeah what's
the name of the high school laguna hills
high school it sounds nice it's pretty
cool imagine there were some attractive
people at that house there was some
attractive people um i'm trying like so
you're the same you're the same age when
the hills dropped right dude like that
was like it was laguna beach was the
first one and then it changed the hills
but laguna beach was when you were in
high school or whatever uh it was right
after i graduated that's where you grew
up yeah
yeah so like i worked at a skate shop
growing up called laguna surfing sport
and
the other lagr look there's one lisa
viejo and one in laguna beach so the
other the kids that were on the show
they worked at the one laguna beach it
was like stephen and yeah yeah yeah
kristin maybe or ever
and i worked at the other one and i
didn't we we people in laguna did not
give a [ __ ] about that show really
because it was i don't know it's just so
weird i don't know why but uh i would
get calls at the shop like hey is a
steven there i'm like oh you got the
[ __ ] wrong one man kid can't even
ollie dude
but that show is big like i mean that
would that's like the jersey shore to us
like we would grow up going to the
jersey shore like that's not what we do
it's very different yeah yeah but yeah
that's funny man yeah um what's the name
of the grocery store that you're you're
pam family with two growing up
dude that's funny wasn't it do you guys
ever hear alpha beta no it was what
alpha behavior is like sounds like
[ __ ] secret yeah
i always tripped out in that name but
like i don't know vaughn's ralph's you
know okay uh stater brothers
there's a bunch of bunch of them right
there that are what do you go to now
oh man i'm gonna uh there's one next to
my house called air juan it's just
but it's the closest one that i don't
have to get in my car and drive anywhere
so i can walk right there but it's a
little expensive it's pricey yeah i
haven't been but i hear good things yeah
what was the name of the uh chinese spot
and the pizza place in your in your
hometown uh
styx was the what no
was that
i think that wasn't the chinese place oh
man
it was a chinese it was
it was called sticks i think it was
called sticks bro i think there was an
uh like a
letter in front of it or something i
can't remember oh
right
probably throw in a good fries oh meg um
and then what was the other one pizza
pizza spot um the pizza store it was
right next to the high school it was
pretty basic every after every high
school football game or whatever
everyone would go there
all the time i get a slice yeah i didn't
high school baby i didn't drink at all
in high school or like i did it after
but it was just the place where you'd go
and all the kids were just hammered like
you know what i mean being nice crazy
you go to all the football games and
stuff like that it was cool just because
my friends were playing right actually
it was pretty interesting when i quit
football they kind of like stopped
hanging out with me because i was just
like a skater now sure and then i had
the skaters that were at the school were
like oh kelly's a jock yeah i was like
you walked into both worlds
i was kind of like in this middle space
i had friends but it was like i didn't
party or anything and go to these weird
events i thought you were a cop
full beard
was there ever any friction between like
the skaters and the jocks and stuff like
that any rumbles i wouldn't say
i don't know if there was rumbles or
all beef
i will say i think the skaters talked
mad [ __ ] on the the jocks and the jocks
didn't give a [ __ ] about that
yeah it was just like oh you [ __ ]
jock ball blah like and the jocks were
getting all the girls and everyone you
know what i mean but the skaters were
just
i don't know they i don't know why you
go fall down somewhere
i'm over here banging the cheerleaders
the skaters in our school they were all
they were all real quiet they were cool
as [ __ ] you know there was a couple of
you know bozos or whatever but for the
most part
they had like this quiet confidence
about them yeah that you knew not that
you would want to but you knew not to
[ __ ] with them and a couple of them
could [ __ ] kick some [ __ ] ass if
their [ __ ] back was up against the
wall oh yeah and i feel like the skater
group always had like one berserker like
one monster yeah that would fight like
nine guys well just like the dude always
had his shirt off could like hold on a
[ __ ] telephone pole sideways and
would just [ __ ] kick the [ __ ] out of
nine people did you ever see the video
of mike valley
[Applause]
or whatever right or they called him a
skater douche or i don't know what the i
don't know i just saw the video of him
yeah let's get back into the rank
fighting five dudes at the same time
what was that what was that on that was
on his that was on a tony hawk's uh
skate tour thing i don't know what video
is in it was in a video
because i remember seeing it really
early on i think they ran into a few
things it was definitely in a cky video
okay i might have been in cko i would
not [ __ ] with that guy dude that's
exactly what i'm saying yeah yeah he was
also randomly in the hangover
that's right he's the guy who pulls up
in the van and hands them their tuxedos
yeah on the highway oh really yeah yeah
yeah
that's like this random cameo but he
beats the [ __ ] out of those oh yeah he
does that was great let's talk about
ladder oh baby let's talk about doing
your family and your loved ones a favor
and not leaving them holding the
proverbial bag sticking it to them one
last time buried in a refrigerator box
out back by the pool which is probably
where i'm gonna end up but i took care
of it you got to get on ladder
you're looking for term life do yourself
a favor get over the ladder and sign up
no doctors no needles talking about
three million coverage yeah let's go
just a few questions about your health
in an application it's easy peasy uh
ladders customers rate them 4.8 out of
five stars on trustpilot and they made
forbes best life insurance list of 2021
what are we even talking about forbes
there you go the same highlights
magazine that daddy we're talking about
forbes shut up the highlights can you
find the boots
all you need is just a few minutes and a
phone or a laptop to apply ladder smart
algorithms work in real time so you
choose and find out if you're instantly
approved no hidden fees cancel any time
get a full refund if you change your
mind in less than 30 days
so
go to ladderlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved baby that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage one more time get a pen a pencil
write it down shove it up your butt
ladderlife.com garbage do it mint mobile
yeah kippy let's talk about mint mobile
baby love mint mobile gang do you like
getting your phone service for fifteen
dollars a month with no hit of feeds and
no catches yeah sure you do but you
probably say listen fat boy fifteen
dollars a month there's gotta be a catch
here's the deal here's the turkey there
is no catch it's all online they passed
the savings right on to you the consumer
do yourself a favor get on mit mobile
yeah guys this isn't big bozo wireless
you know what i mean this ain't the big
box stores this ain't no huge
conglomerate this ain't that okay
talking about ryan reynolds whatever
guys for anyone who hates their big
phone bill mint mobiles offers offers
premium wireless for just 15 bucks a
month and it's true my wife the
international investor the bird has been
using it for about seven years now not
even messing around she's been a
customer before they were a client daddy
one
family we keep it in a family over here
it's easy peasy mint mobile gives you
the best rate whether you're buying one
or a family and mint knows family start
at just two lines that's a [ __ ] what are
we doing here it goes
all plans come with a limited talk and
text high speed data delivered on
nation's largest 5g network use your own
phone with any mint mobile plan and keep
your same phone number along with all
your existing contacts ain't nothing to
lose switch a bit mobile and get premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks a month to get your new wireless
plan
for just 15 clams a month and get that
plan shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com garbage that's
mittmobile.com garbage cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month mobile.com
subscribers back to the show
yeah have you ever gotten to a fight
with a security guard no nothing like
that i don't i don't do no it's like
it's when you got older
like when you start doing your sponsor
i'm like
people come at you pretty quick because
they're like hey get the [ __ ] out of
here because they're probably sick of
dealing with skaters coming to the spot
but like hey i'm sorry i'm just doing
this because it's my like this is what i
love to do and i'm doing it for a job i
don't mean to ruin yeah and they're like
oh
okay yeah cool you get one more try it's
all good yeah you know what i mean i
never really got that why they were such
dicks about like i understand maybe the
insurance but it's not like the
skateboards ever really ruined anything
well no they're like they can they like
you see like on the ledges there like
rails there's wax and like it's like all
grinded up these colors it you know
grinds down the edges okay yeah and so i
understand that but at the same time
it's just like
you built the perfect spot yeah good
like but dude it was that's not my fault
your place ripped yeah it's [ __ ]
amazing it was always some [ __ ]
security guard that looks like me
[ __ ] with his shirt undone trying to
chase four or five of you guys around
it's like dude this is not gonna end
well it's being filmed you look a
[ __ ] idiot yeah put your mace away
and get back in your car
it's not worth it
uh man what were the vacations like
growing up
i went to
a family vacation i went to my family
had like this uh time share in in maui
those were before really yeah i was
timeshare yeah timeshares are trash
timeshares are for sure trashy but
maui's all right pr must have been slow
that year
yikes it was tight though i went out
there remember that's where i saw ace
ventura for the first time
i was [ __ ] i watched it i recorded
family memories yeah i quoted it the
whole trip and my sisters hated me dude
it was [ __ ] it was that and what was
uh oh man what's the guy
the [ __ ] uh man i have to think i
can't i can't remember his name i'll do
that edit that out
i got it imposed uh and you guys had the
beach house we had a beach house how
often would you go there would you just
do that in the summer or the time share
as well so it's extra trash yeah i'm
just trashy everywhere you have a
timeshare about yeah was your regular
house a timeshare too
i only had it two weeks a year hey wait
for the clarks to get out of there get
back in my room
i went there
once every like two months okay and it
was cool
it was like literally on the beach and
then like el nino happened yeah dude
dude i went there after it happened in
the house literally was filled with sand
like literally filled with sand it was
pretty wild to see but yeah we we
stopped going after that really did they
get rid of it uh they renovated it yeah
but that time my parents were like oh
we're good and i was like not dude when
i started surfing and i was so over the
like the fish and i didn't understand
the sets coming in i would get destroyed
so i just kind of like skateboarding is
like i can control my surroundings and
so i just that's why i kind of got in
the scene can you see a shark
no i just like stepped on a fish once
and it felt really weird that's it you
know what i mean like you know once you
step in the fish and it's like you're
like dude [ __ ] that yeah dude
get a bad case
[Laughter]
uh what's your go-to order at 7-eleven
if you're going to get a snack what are
you getting dude i used to run the hot
dogs
which is a horrible [ __ ] thing wow
it's all right shout out to the big bite
what are you talking about i don't know
what they put in that chili god damn i
used to do that now it's more like i'll
get like a clif bar or something like
that i kind of cleaned up my uh get
older of course yeah but i would just
crush hot dogs and go skate all day back
in the day i was chubby dude i was
chubbed up yeah were you a slurpee man
at one point yeah do the the suicide
stuff we just get all the different
flavors
[Applause]
good times that's [ __ ] awesome yeah
uh what were the pets like growing up uh
i had a dog i had a golden retriever
named quincy um that was uh
the dog it was crazy my mom would tell
me it's like yeah you were crying one
time on the other side of the house and
quincy heard me and went and got my mom
right now and like you know like
whatever something's going on um what
kind of dog was he a goal retreat yeah
it was sick it was golden retriever and
um
i had a dog named barkley he was a
cockapoo okay and he was like my actual
dog during like my teenage years
yeah yeah so that was like weird because
i when he passed away you know it's like
you never think a dog would be so so
special but when he passed away it was
like me and my family like wow this was
[ __ ] horrible how old were he passed
away 27 27 that's tough we it's like
parents not that they don't think about
it but like you get married you get a
dog then you have kids when those kids
are 10 or 11 that dog's checking out and
that's [ __ ] dramatic that's very
tremendous
baby you got to learn i know my mom did
that with our uh first uh german
shepherd mike we went to like like pop
warner football practice one day and
came back and oh
yep 86.
just
later out of nowhere yeah out of nowhere
that's horrible man that was brutal
sounds like a nice lady jesus christ
he was looking at me
he was going through my purse
ah that's good ever have a burrito for
breakfast for days
dude
breakfast burrito you're my new favorite
person
for [ __ ] days
this is toby's two worlds coming
together
for real my whole life has led up to
this video
that's a huge thing like uh the
breakfast burritos in southern
california burritos like in l.a
especially in san diego that's huge like
mexican food down there um yeah called a
california burrito if you guys ever
heard of that what's that like it's just
like you get like was it chicken or
whatever steak but you put french fries
in it it's like
it's all it's the whole deal you get
behind that yeah yeah yeah yeah french
fries it's pretty like hammered late
night type style nice food but yeah i
like it
um what's the credit score like now
credit score yeah pretty good yeah
i actually trip out on that yeah i used
to like i i said i've said it before
somewhere i think but like i had didn't
have a credit card until i was 35. i
just got my first one and like two years
ago maybe we were in this studio so
within two years and my credit limit was
300 or 200. wow yeah bad but now we're
doing good shout out to capital one yeah
yeah i started i just actually got
another credit card recently i was like
i'm an expert but i got like a new car
[ __ ] it's like yeah it's pretty good
right now i'm stoked but i just never
thought that i never thought of that
until 35 right weird yeah they gave me
they gave us a credit card when i went
to college and [ __ ] it probably had
like 500 bucks on it just ran it up once
yeah never even thought about it again
yeah and then as an adult it's like your
credit score is negative 54.
because of 500. yeah been digging out of
that hole for a long time uh
what kind you got a amex uh no i got uh
what do i have uh citibank i have like
the american ex uh not american spread
sorry you said that uh american airlines
like
credit card so i get like the yeah and
then i got like a bank of america visa
card you're an american airlines guy
yeah your role well
when i go on all these trips for
traveling for like contests and skating
like my friend was like dude just go on
one airline you gotta
comics are the same thing earlier make
one just stay on it because it'll pay
off a lot of skaters would do delta yeah
it's a big one and then i just got
randomly like i had gotten a lot of
flights in america american i was like
i'm just going to stay yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so americans are right
that's a nice outfit for sure you fly
first class now no i'm not there i had
i've i'm still working on it i mean
sometimes they'll bump me up but i'm not
there yet yeah yeah we're playing that
game too yeah it's a little bit more
we'll do it yeah trying to get those
points trying to get next year
straightened out yeah
trying to get silver
so you've been on you've been on trips
to china right yeah yeah uh who'd you go
with i went with expedition and lrg back
then did they send you to china first
class or was that
i never went first class like that i i
did go to australia on the on the way
home this is actually kind of funny like
i'm the young kid on the team there's
like og pros like lrg trip the carl
watson rob g like all these older adelmo
i'm the young kid you know rob g sure
[ __ ] hanging out with him last night
[Laughter]
he's got good weed
oh [ __ ] man yeah and then they got in
the plane it was like it's hit some
weird ass number and i go up it's like
upstairs first class and like all the
pros are like in the back and like
regular spots oh just like she's laid
out first class i'm like i just got
lucky out of the group just randomly got
it that was or whatever yeah that was
the one time where i was like this is
what it's like yeah you never want to go
back after that because it's time
i'm not paying that much money i don't
know crazy skateboarders we sleep on the
couch man i don't give a [ __ ] like i'll
pay i'll sit in the back i don't care
how far is how long is that flight to
china oh it's like a i'm going to say
like a
12-hour flight or something but
australia is worse right australia i
think it's longer right 18 it's like
something like that dude stairs on a
plane i don't trust that
it's [ __ ] too big how gnarly it's a
huge ass [ __ ] nuts that's [ __ ]
nuts yeah but first class dude i'll take
it who is i think virgin has bars in
them like you can get up and go walk to
the bar and like to stand at the bar
like in business class oh i could
if you get on that plane it's like
you're at a club
it's a yeah weird but like i'll [ __ ]
with it
um do you guys celebrate christmas
growing up oh hell yeah wow what'd you
do real tree fake tree
real tree real trees
colored lights on that tree for days
yeah okay how the lights are trapped
and you got the uh and you got the thing
on top you got the ornaments yeah on top
did you tinsel on it or no tinsel no
tinsel i i don't know i don't know if i
ever did that like with the tin you
haven't ever make the popcorn string and
have that go around it no all right
people do that i was like well people do
that
and how about the outside of the house
would you do colored lights out there
white lights yeah yeah uh colored lights
and then actually my we did the back was
uh we did the color lights in the back
but we did eventually did it my mom's
house was all white lights and we did it
one year like just like 15 20 years ago
they already stayed up they haven't gone
down it's like a perfect backyard
backyard with white christmas lights all
right that's [ __ ] good
it's a proper background it's a good
hangout yeah yeah
i feel like you're in a wine cooler
commercial i [ __ ] love it well my
backyard where i grew up is is
ridiculous it overlooks like all of
orange county it's like i grew up in
this hill it's like pretty nuts yeah i
just grew up like i didn't i just all i
knew and then i moved away i was like
whoa that was damn you had it made in
the shade i can't even believe i grew up
in that that's cool man so it was cool
man uh were you a bagel bites or pizza
rolls ooh
damn uh
i'm gonna say
bagel bites okay i never really answered
yeah i think i would
i don't know i was like you go you know
go to uh costco yeah and you just they
have all the little like snacks you can
get whatever they have like little corn
dogs and [ __ ]
and we never got those but a couple kids
had them those things were wild that was
my foray into corn dogs i was seeing
that he never looked
there's a back
wrapped in a hot dog wrapped in a
pancake let's go yeah that's pretty sick
forgot about those little things little
bangers
uh what about frozen pizza would you
guys do frozen pizza oh yeah tombstone
really
that was very classy hella tombstone
right yeah uh you had my and i also
my mom would get me i dude i ate like a
maniac i would
you go out like i don't know i can't
believe my mom would let me do this i
would go like twice a day to mcdonald's
or something like that
two big macs
cheese only large fry large coke i do
that twice a day sometimes really that's
for a kid that's a lot of calories now
cheese only no pickles no no no no
onions no special sauce
i was really strict eating as a kid so
pizza
burgers chicken nuggets okay i'm a
nugget man myself
but now uh now i expanded my mind so i
can eat other things gotcha yeah what
about uh school lunches growing up did
you buy or did you bring your bring your
lunch depends in elementary school the
food there was trash yeah
like it literally sucked you'd think
it'd be good yeah but like this is like
the nine no one cared in the 90s it was
just like slop and keep it moving yeah
and then like when i got to junior
junior high they would have like uh they
had pretzels with like chili and cheese
like the soft pretzels and i was like
that's my [ __ ] right there i would crush
that and that'd be good i didn't really
bring food or school or food to school
shout out to the super pretzel soft prep
you guys ever go on a cruise as a family
never did that nice
hot air balloon
no i just talked about that the other
day how [ __ ] insane that would be but
no it would scare the [ __ ] out that
would be that's my friends were like i
would rather do jump off a plane or
whatever [ __ ] going in a hot air
it's too slow it's like you're just
[ __ ] you're like am i going to die
now am i going to die now
if you want to get down you just have to
like chill yeah yeah
it's like i don't like that dude no what
about skydiving skydiving no i don't
think i'll ever do that there's no
reason for me to do that okay
have you guys done it no
[ __ ] out of here
that's the only way to balance it out
oh my gosh
do you know karate
no
do you want to learn
[Laughter]
toby get him
are these questions you ask everybody
yeah
[Laughter]
uh what about devil sticks you know how
to use those oh the things yeah i did it
once but i don't know how to use it can
you hacky sack
uh not good okay i kicked the ball
probably three times okay that's good
it's good answer it's a good warm-up to
skate actually gotcha yeah that's limber
yeah um have you ever worn a kangal hat
no
do you do you own a suit
no
tuxedo
no no
i got one uh when was the last time you
bought your own clothes
ooh
uh
i don't know uh jeez you're flooded with
gear yeah that's the cool thing about
skateboarding this guy's awesome dude
i'll get you guys gear yeah give me gear
dude i've got 5x stuff over there
there's no 400 pound skateboarders dude
hey lrg though they're
g does make like
a lot of sizes and uh get gear up yeah
dude
we gotta get you skating yeah do you you
guys don't get do you guys get free [ __ ]
for like doing comedy stuff or how does
that work uh free drinks at the bar
usually that's how you take full
advantage of it yeah yeah yeah uh i mean
our sponsors for the pod center stuff
yeah yeah we got everything we sponsor
but not like skateboarding you so you're
looking we don't have like i don't yeah
we don't have like clothing yeah
sponsors i mean like so the cool thing
with like doing the team manager stuff i
sponsor kids with shoes or some pros i
can send myself shoes i can sell myself
grip tape i can send myself wheels i can
order gear because i'm sponsored by lrg
i get all the boards i want all the
trucks all the wheels so it's like
that's a cool maybe i didn't make a lot
of money growing up as a skater sure but
i got everything i wanted to do i always
had gear and i got to travel for free
yeah so that was like the fun part you
know what i mean that first that first
couple things of gear you're like [ __ ]
this is awesome it's christmas every
month dude yeah you're waiting at home
and like the ups guy comes up and you're
like just waiting for him he drops off a
box and it's it's cool man what on you
right now did you did you buy
the hat the hat that's it that's it what
about the underwear god for free too
shout out to stance
i got the socks from stance too
s pants lrg t-shirt i'm a huge dodger
fan so like i just i have to yeah i kind
of just live with a [ __ ] dream over
here dude i'm so jealous
he's head to toe and merch i [ __ ]
love it
oh that's a good piece of business
well you need at the counter at a diner
you a counter guy
uh at a diner gnost at the booth okay
yeah
but yeah if it like there's alcohol
involved i'll sit at the bar but like
you know what i mean like i don't know
it depends if i'm also
from solo with friends right is that a
thing i don't know solo with the bar is
nice still let the bars nice
i would rather go sit at the bar by
myself and you'll have lunch there i'll
have lunch there if i was i'll rat if i
had friends i'd rather sit at the booth
with the homies yeah yeah yeah with the
squad yep
uh
do you have name brand luggage
uh i don't know well the company has a
name but it's not like
it's not necessarily it's vulcan
randomly okay welcome clothing yeah they
said they sent us a box a long time ago
so that works
okay
um
ever been to burning man no coachella no
i'll never do that [ __ ] okay i'm no no
disrespect to it it's just you're you're
just out there it's a lot it's like i
like it
i like it
good answers yeah is there a
family dessert
or a family party appetizer that's well
known within your family like your
aunt's um
banana pudding recipe or rice pudding
recipe or like a buffalo chicken dip
anything like that in the family damn um
that's a great question i don't know if
there was like a specific thing but i
don't i don't nobody had a famous dish
nobody at a famous date uh it's a good
thing i mean my mom would just make
she'd get really drunk sometimes and
make chicken
and she'd make this chicken and she
wouldn't cook it all the way and put it
for down and i was like mom you can't
get hammer to make not cooked chicken
i didn't answer this rare that's not
exactly what i mean but that's all right
but but no she's a great cook it was
just funny how that stuff happened but
no that's nothing too crazy how do you
feel about the rotisserie chicken oh i
love that she would bring that home from
the grocery shop
that [ __ ] is
banging they're all right uh do you
currently own any two dollar bills
no
do you guys i have one do you guys use
hold on to it or do you i tried to spend
it when i was really poor i didn't have
any money i tried to spend it and the
guy did whatever i'm not touching that
thing the trashy thing is that at some
point when you're when you're a kid an
uncle or somebody gives you a two dollar
bill
you thought it was like like it's gonna
be worth it it's gonna be worth more
money at some point that's the the
thought random thing i have i have this
thing full of change and i have two
silver dollar bills or whatever yeah
yeah like that's like the weirdest
rarest thing i have but that's who i
don't see those anymore i don't think
they're that rare but
yeah i don't know that's where two
dollar bills yeah i don't know i don't
ever use them though that's our what
what what is the container that holds
the change
uh it's just little i don't even know
it's like this little
glass bowl whatever bowl thing with a
little lid on top it's not like a two
liter with the top cut off or anything
no no no that's apparently
[Music]
[Laughter]
from the waist up let's go i want to get
i want to get one of those things when
do you when do you cash it in
like you go to the coin store machine
and cash it in yeah i would go with the
coins
have you seen those things where you
just dump it in there yeah one time
that's my banking institution what are
you talking about i was so i was like i
[ __ ] don't like they take the
percentage nine percent or seven so i
was like i went to the bank and buy and
i just [ __ ] gave them all the change
that i had it was like they took it yeah
they did yeah i was there for quite some
time but they hated
i was like maybe i shouldn't do that
next time i'm gonna do the coin stock
porn star likes to wet their beak a
little too much yeah i'll tell you that
take that down to the cayman's
straight
[ __ ] off short have you ever gone ghost
hunting
no okay
ever had your palm read
i don't think by someone professional
a couple amateurs maybe a couple friends
you got calluses dude
i do have one house right here [ __ ]
damn random thing i'll just shout out i
jump rope a lot okay because i hurt
myself skating so much that i got into
jump roping shout out cross rope jump
ropes are the best
[Laughter]
dude i do i'll be here i'm gonna show
you guys you're gonna be like what the
[ __ ] you're kind of weird uh but i have
that it's been there for like five
months from the thing from that i'm like
dude i've never had that so yeah that's
good yeah it's a good time you're doing
a good job with the jump rope
kid's active um
you pee in the shower
yes
i have yeah
we're not the feds take it easy
i like how it's like my mom gets drunk
and makes chickens do you pee in the
shower i don't know what you're talking
about
are you flossing every day no never my
sister's dentist and she hates that
when's the last time you were at the
dentist
a year and a half ago okay
that's alright the cool thing about
having a sister's dentist is that i get
like free stuff like whatever free
checkups but i don't go see her okay i
had to pay for [ __ ] in his life
cozy [ __ ]
i got a merch deal with the dentist
i needed somebody to work at mickey d's
and you're all set keep you in big macs
check out socal dentistry
[Laughter]
[Music]
is it a drugstore or a pharmacy
uh
i guess it's like what is it cbs yeah so
what would you call what would you say
would you say i'm going to the pharmacy
or i'm going to the drugstore
i would say drugstore okay yeah i think
it's what it was all right that's trash
uh do you know any of the lyrics to the
battles from eight mile
no okay okay
that's good that's a good sign who's
your mom's favorite singer
bob seger or
shout out to the silver bullet fan
the streisand
shout out to my mom she's the best
sucker for showtime that's [ __ ]
awesome that's a good time that was
great my stepmom loved seeger dude she
had a porsche growing up like when uh
when i was a kid she would rock bob
seeger to top off like top top down we
just drive around laguna bob seeger i
was like this little kid in the side
sitting there that's [ __ ] awesome
out there working on the night moves
were your crystal light family growing
up yes nice crystal light it was a lim
the lemonade flavor because they had
other flavors but get out of here with
that
that euro trash straight up the middle
lemonade yeah yeah let's go um if you
buy a six-pack and you go you're taking
it home
and you put it in the fridge yeah six
pack of beer yeah yeah you take them out
or leave them in the six-pack that's a
great question uh it depends
on if i'm going to go somewhere after
but usually i just put them in there
just just like just like just put the
box put the whole thing up yeah yeah
yeah because
i don't know because you're garbage yeah
i got
this is a toby question but you ever
walk on a highway
you're going to walk down no no no no no
that's i i trip out if i see people
doing that yeah
that's not great i would see that in
china a bunch randomly okay so you would
just be dude driving in china's wild you
drove i didn't drive personally
in the car like they really like it's
it's people are on the like street yeah
uh they're honking they're only going 50
miles an hour on a freeway like if
you're going up to a car and you're
going up a little faster that'll honk
just just like honk just to let them
know that you're there gotcha it's too
much it's just there's a lot going on
there but
good for skateboarding how do you feel
about cold pasta we have cold spaghetti
in the morning i do uh i used to i cut
out carbs cut all that stuff out okay
because i can't i would get yeah so i
just cut the carbs out okay good good
good good uh what kind of car are you
whipping now
i got a lexus nx uh 350. nice i just got
it i'm really stoked awesome yeah
congratulations uh 2022.
yeah i'm hyped dude i would at least or
do you own it i i ha i had a car and i
just like gave them i got a good it's a
lease okay or whatever but um for three
years and i realized i'm like in three
years car where do you i don't even know
what cars are gonna be like like they
could be all electric they could you
know what i mean like and i was just
like
flying through space
we'd be flying all the time man but i
was just like i want to get the car that
i hope my dad had one growing up i
always thought that would be so cool to
like own or like have alexis to drive
sure so i i just got it that's [ __ ]
awesome man congratulations
congratulations thank you i appreciate
it the 90s dad that drove a lexus yeah
[ __ ]
was [ __ ] classy had the had the phone
in the car yeah the big one
my dad had that in a jeep
it's like he was calling an airstrike
uh well you use you go to the gas
station we use the squeegee at the gas
station to clean anything else but the
windshield well you do like the doors
i think i did that once yeah like i used
to have a purple honda yeah i i
uh i saw you i would no i just do the
windshield okay yeah and now i'll do the
windows on the side
lexus with the with the squeegee
he only accepts they're gonna look at
that like
[Laughter]
when i was a kid i had
i thought i was buying it was a cloudy
day and i thought i was buying this like
black
honda oh my god and they delivered the
car like a week later it was full on
purple i had my shades on dude i was
like what the [ __ ] is this
and then so like a couple of they saw
you
give them the purple one yeah
tricked me with that one and then my
homies dude i bought a car in a cloud a
day
and then by homie uh he he had a piece
of story ever well this gets even better
like my homie had my car was all dusty
and my homie had this like piece of
plastic i don't know why did it be dro
i called a dode but like drew a huge
dick on the hood of my car the whole
thing and i thought it was like oh to
scratch it off it just stayed i had
basically car keyed a huge dick on my
purple honda for when i was a little
like like a high school kid so i got i
got roasted pretty good for that one
they had my number there how long have
you been friends with johnny knox
that's a real
move right there
has anybody ever in your family ever
uttered the phrase i should have killed
you when i had the job
maybe my sister i'm scared
not you specifically
but i heard a family member say that not
too long ago and it really struck me i
should have killed them when they had a
chance i knew that would just happen to
you because you've been spending so much
time at home i'm like oh he just heard
that he just heard that i should have
killed him when i had the chance
to relax lady
oh
god um have you ever farted in your hand
and made someone else smell it no okay
that's that's raw
you fart in an uber
i have not like not loud
you know dude
the public loud farts
like you you do the silent dude imagine
being a fat guy you're blamed no matter
what
yeah they bring you in you ever seen
that one uh it's a family guy when peter
and some dude get in the uh elevator i
mean like he farts he's like it was you
[Music]
any turquoise jewelry
no okay i got a quick one uh have you
ever pissed in a bottle
in a moving vehicle yes for days dude
like on skate tours
you're doing that all the time because
like you're going from like six hour
drive and the driver is like
we're all drinking beers in the back
whatever like he's not stopping sure
every 10 minutes to like let us piss so
you just get a gatorade bottle you just
have out of it yeah just go for it dude
i know you're probably off them now but
when you were if you were having a
burger with a bun and you're eating the
burger yeah when you pick a bite first
of all do you cut it in half
no okay when you put it back on the
plate do you turn it upside down or do
you put it back right side up right side
up okay do people do i'm an upside down
guy the the science behind it uh
is the top is more structurally sound so
it's like it's easier to do this okay
then like intro oh yeah yeah
it does make sense it's like a backhoe
yeah i guess i don't know if i ever saw
anyone do that back home well let's get
a burger yeah it's a east coast thing
all
right
what do you where you live now you live
at an apartment or a house i live in an
apartment in venice beach okay yeah um
what kind of bed do you have in there
you have a king queen dude it's a
sponsor for sure
no i'm trying to get one i'm trying to
get a bet like i've had this bed for
[ __ ] ever and it's a full-size bed
it's a little spot that i have it and
i'm trying to get a new bed but i can't
i'm so like
uh indecisive i'm buying furniture it
took me it took me two
two years to get my place actually what
it is but all i'm missing is a new bed
okay so i would recommend helix sleep
promo code garbage take a two minute
sleep quiz that's just me i don't know
i'll [ __ ] do it yeah is it up against
the wall or is it in the middle of the
room it's
there's a little nook in the right hand
corner and so i put it in that little
nook and it's
it's like i would get a king but the
king won't fit in can you get out on
either no no no no no no you gotta get
out the ones you gotta get the one side
it's like the way my it's positioned
dude i have i have a studio apartment
and i have a tv right there and i have a
tv right it's like the most bachelor pad
like sleeping in a [ __ ] sports bar
exactly
but that's it's cool i like it there and
what's the betting situation do you have
a complete set like pillowcases
does it all match or is it all for sure
yeah sound comforter
uh yeah yeah for down cover yeah does it
have a duvet cover on it yeah no yep
yeah yeah okay
shout out to kelly
not bad yeah uh do you open your eyes
underwater uh not in the ocean but in
like maybe the pool i don't know i
haven't done it for a while no i
wouldn't do any more when i was a kid i
i got it like a lot of chlorine in my
eyes and it kind of [ __ ] me up so i
don't really do it too much you have any
fireworks in your house right now no
okay
okay ever jump off a trampoline into a
pool
no that sounds fun though wow you're
surprised on that you haven't done that
i think parents would be a little i if
you're sure i mean i'm not asking my mom
to watch
i mean it was she was at work i think my
mom would be like oh [ __ ] that's kind of
nervous dangerous the first one's
awesome but then the second one you're
wet so you lose your feet you know it's
it's bad yeah the first one you're like
this is the [ __ ] great thing it's
real trampoline falls when people like
jump off of roofs on the trampolines and
they think they're going to like spray
off
combustion or sometimes it snaps they
just go straight through the ground did
you skate on the trampoline with like a
deck a lot i never i never really got
good at that but there's some skaters
that consider wild really really good
yeah
back in the shower do you brush your
teeth in there no okay i do it outside
what kind of
soap shampoo you use in there
uh i think i have doves uh bars bars and
i have the shampoo in there the dove
shampoo okay three and two and one yeah
uh no i have conditioner too really yeah
i don't know is double sponsor
i know i feel like they're about to be
i'm super down dude it's the one thing
that i pay for than this ad yeah
and i'm furious about that
it's good has anybody in your family
ever claimed to see any ufo no nobody no
no okay
no have you ever left a bad yelp review
nope i've never really
yeah left one at all neither have i yeah
even if you're not eating it now have
you been in the past been an egg
benedict man
i uh at one point yeah yeah yeah it's
good okay
pretty good
anybody in your family drive a pt
cruiser no okay
no let's say you were going to a wedding
all right one of your buddies is getting
married mm-hmm what are you dropping in
the envelope what are we talking about
here what do you like casualized
[ __ ] i still owe my last friend some
money for this thing
stop right there
that says enough mr wait a minute wait a
minute how long ago was this wedding uh
a month ago two months ago yeah that's
all right yeah in dirtbag law you got a
calendar year yeah yeah i heard that
somewhere and i'm still i can't do it i
just saw him the other day and i told
him that he's like no no it's all good
[ __ ] whatever oh you had to do that i
still got you dude well then yeah it's
all good uh i've been i'm going to a
wedding next two weeks so i i gotta look
into that i gotta give him some money
okay yeah yeah all right thanks for
reminding me of course
uh
fat bastard
toby got that
um
have you ever taken a bath at a hotel
yeah i have wow yeah but was it was it
an epsom salt bath no i was i was with
someone okay
[Laughter]
i like that was it a big one or a
regular sized tub that was a big one
yeah yeah okay all right get the
sauerkraut you know your birthday you
got to get the sweet sure oh yeah sure
okay do you have a favorite flavor of
gatorade even if you don't drink it now
oh i still drink it now uh a nightclub i
drink it all the time it the orange
really yeah orange i never liked it when
i was a kid in overtime like damn orange
is the best i respect it yeah that's
pretty good yeah i'm going back and
forth here i'm not really
sure
on him
okay
are we watching this are we on the same
show right now
orange gatorade
literally anything with food will
convince him that you're like you could
be royalty he's like well he does like
pickles
i do like pickles
anyone your family ever represent
themselves in court
uh no my sister's a lawyer but she would
not i don't i don't think she's done yet
she hasn't been to have to do that yeah
have you ever been to anybody's first
call when they were locked up if they
got locked up no no no okay have you
guys had that yeah really i've been a
first call
what the [ __ ] what are you doing the
numbers have to go down and get them out
what do you mean what did i do but like
wrong number hang out i could get my boy
out of the lockout
it was a friday he would have been
sitting there until monday i can't do
that
he had a show the next night [ __ ] uh do
you have butter at your house you have
butter in your home no i don't no butter
not my spot no really yeah okay
you're not [ __ ] with it i i [ __ ] with
butter
but i just i used to eat so much and i
just realized that i don't need it is
yours fridge stocked like if we went
there right now would we if we showed up
at your house right now if we would you
be able to make us a meal
right now since no because i did it on
purpose
like going out of town nice so i don't
want to like go to trader joe's and
stack it up and then just dip out sure
yeah so but when i'm home and i'm at
home for a while it's pretty cool you'll
do a grocery shopping a lot of stuff for
sure you have a swiffer at the house yes
nice yeah yeah the the [ __ ] yeah i
have one of those no is it the electric
one no okay it's like a regular one yeah
yeah what about a vacuum cleaner you
have a vacuum a vacuum cleaner what are
you rocking i don't know my my my
landlord's like my best friend and he
gave these that's weird yeah
dude i get that i get amazing rent and
it gives me free [ __ ] all the time
[Laughter]
hanging out with your regular videos
with their landlords i also picture like
an old guy is it no i was like a young
kid
he shouts with jeff gallas but homie
yeah there we go you said if i get a
free yeah exactly that's how i came on
here go to gallows apartments.com
because that's why i came here
that's good
yeah he uh he skates oh okay so we
became friends through skating and then
he's like oh i actually own this
property he's literally nice all right
that's weird so i thought you just like
randomly applied for a place and like mr
jenkins like this guy is [ __ ] awesome
some old war vet
yeah wait so how does the vacuum cleaner
prone to that relationship he gave you a
vacuum cleaner it's where he lived in
japan for a long time it's a random
japanese vacuum
like all the controls are japanese
so i have like no idea it's probably
like a blender oh i know what i just hit
the green button and that's all i know
what to do dude the moral of this
episode is that if you're chill enough
you don't have to pay for anything in
your life
[Laughter]
steve will give you a vacuum
can you kick flip
north korean toaster at your house
i don't know what he's doing
come on
this guy is 360 flipped his way into the
coolest life ever yeah
oh my gosh
oh my gosh
north korean toaster
he's been using that line for months
i think i'm pretty good yeah
yeah
i think uh he's trash
that's game set and max
i already knew i was gonna do yeah yeah
but i'll tell you what a [ __ ] goddamn
good time kelly i'll tell you that thank
you my kind of guy ladies and gentlemen
kelly hart thank you so much for coming
and sit with us uh anything you got
coming up you want the folks here today
walk away plug the pods
whatever uh
thank you guys for having me on of
course anytime thank you for hitting me
up uh
i'm just we're announcing right now
because i'm actually gonna do it right
after i'm done uh that i'm back
officially back on lrg we're like
redoing or not redoing it but we're
building up the skate program okay all
super hyped on that shout out kfd carl
watson chico um watch the nine club if
you can if you like skateboarding even
if you don't even if you don't also you
had normand all you have to do check out
i mean everybody's comedy fans listen to
this uh check out norman's episode of
the nightclub please
huge marksman huge mark normandy yeah
he's been on your guy's show but yeah of
course yeah so um that and um s footwear
don brown and
yeah no thank you guys i appreciate it
thank you this has been great man thank
you fantastic what do you got for him uh
guys get uh tickets to our live shows uh
they're selling out so get those tickets
now it's a good time we'll see you out
there come see us gang we love you and
we'll see you next week peace